so thanks to some recently released
court documents we've learned that
multiple of the accused
rioters from the january 6th
insurrection attempt
tried to use uh the legal defense
donald trump made me do it now they
tried but at least
so far it's been unsuccessful because
the court
said no way and in fact one of the
people who tried this
is that guy known as the q anon shaman
jacob chansley who was photographed in
the house chamber wearing like a viking
hat of some kind
and his lawyer was actually um
making the case that
what um jacob chansley did
would not have happened were it not for
the words
and the actions of president donald
trump his lawyer said
if it weren't for trump my client your
honor
would never even have been in washington
d.c in support of the president and
were it not for the specific words of
the then president on january 6th
saying we're going to march down
pennsylvania avenue or whatever
the defendant would not have walked down
pennsylvania avenue and would never have
gone near never mind inside the u.s
capitol building
saying my client did it because donald
trump told him to
this was part of his lawyer trying to
get him out on bail instead of having
him stay in pre-trial detention
and his lawyer argued he's not dangerous
he wasn't even sincerely there due to
his own beliefs it was just because of
trump trump made him do it
and the judge in the case royce lamberth
said quote
even taking defendants claim at face
value
it does not persuade the court that the
defendant would not pose a danger to
others if released
if the defendant truly believes that the
only reason he participated
in an assault on the u.s capitol was to
comply with president trump's orders
this shows the defendant's inability or
refusal
to exercise his independent judgment
and conform his behavior to the law
in other words the judge is saying if
trump really convinced him to do it
it's still on him and that doesn't tell
me if i release him he won't be a threat
because someone else could convince him
to do something such just as dangerous
or stupid whether he believes
trump wants him to do it has nothing to
do with whether his actions conform with
the law and you might remember the other
version of this that we talked about
i think it was a couple of weeks ago a
defendant's lawyer
in another one of these rioters lawyers
claimed that the accused was suffering
from
quote fox itis and quote
fox mania and that it is fox news
rather than donald trump that are to
blame now big picture
this is not a valid legal excuse
answering someone else's call to break
the law
doesn't make it irrelevant that you
still broke the law
but there are cases when if someone was
really manipulated or forced into
breaking the law i mean
in a way i'm not comparing trump to
charles manson but
when you look at the charles manson case
charles manson
if i recall correctly i mean this is
just occurring to me now
if i recall correctly charles manson
himself did not actually kill anyone but
he directed others to do it and yet he
was found legally guilty
uh because he brainwashed manipulated
others etc there are
circumstances where if you were really
manipulated or
forced into breaking the law and forced
into breaking the law is an even
different thing
courts can consider that and it can
impact guilt versus innocence
and it can impact sentencing but under
federal statutes
in this particular situation the law
wouldn't see the trump defense
as a valid defense it wouldn't see fox
itis and fox mania
as valid defenses just because a nutty
childish clown
tells you to do something even if that
someone is the president
does not make it a valid legal defense
particularly when you are dealing with
these
specific federal statutes but this
is sort of a version of stochastic
terrorism as i've said before
it's really hard to hold people
accountable for that but if you have a
large enough audience
if remember glenn beck when he used to
have i think it was a
fox news or cnn show glenn beck ranting
about the tides foundation which he
became obsessed with every day
statistically someone in his audience is
going to hear that and say i'm going to
go and do something about the tides
foundation in case in point there was a
guy arrested
by california highway patrol driving to
the tides foundation to do
who the hell knows what with a large
enough audience when you start
saying someone should do x and if only
someone did y
the likelihood that at least one person
in this case hundreds or thousands of
people will try to do it goes up and up
and up it's almost it's kind of like a
silly version
of the nuremberg defense the difference
being
none of these people are in the chain of
command the trump writers were not
in the chain of command where you could
even say i was following orders in a
sense
there were no risks or punishments if
you just stayed the hell home if the q
anon shaman said you know what instead
of going to dc i'll stay at home
no one was going to punish him for that
there was not going to be any risk to
doing that
he would have been fine and so that also
furthers the reason why it's not a
particularly good
defense now even if it doesn't make a
difference for these specific people
the funny or maybe the ir ironic thing
in people pointing to trump as the
reason why they did this
could be something that comes up in a
justice department investigation
or a house congressional investigation
into trump's role
but i don't expect that will go very far
at least at holding donald trump
accountable
the other possibility is that while
claiming
trump made me do it might make no
difference
in their criminal trials civil trials
are a whole different thing and one
lawyer wrote to me and said
the trump made me do it defense could be
something that plays a role in a civil
trial
if there were to be one last thought it
is not beyond me
the irony of people who claim to
represent a political ideology
that preaches and values and prioritizes
personal responsibility
who then get charged with crimes that
they did and immediately claim as their
defenses
fox news convinced me or trump made me
do it
it's pitiful it's pitiful and pathetic
and it is again a reminder
that their stated values and principles
are merely
stated they are not really sincerely
held values and principles they abandon
them
abandon them instantly when it's no
longer convenient